global inflation has hit its highest
level since
2008 oecd says
and then we also have some market
indicators from berkshire hathaway
warren buffett and uh it looks like
there may be a big
market crash coming or we're also
hearing that we're in a v-shaped
recovery and demand is so high supply
hasn't caught up yet the economy is just
recovering too quickly
back when the market crashed in 2008 the
media kept saying everything was fine
bye bye bye it's fine it's fine
because if they start saying it's not
fine then the market crashes
but they keep telling everyone it is
fine and then the market crashes and
then people don't trust the media
anymore
so i hope y'all are getting ready for
this lumber prices are through the roof
there's a meme going around showing a
thousand dollars of the lumber back and
fall
today you can't get anything done it's
really crazy it's making it extremely
expensive to buy houses
it's increasing the cost of houses by
like forty thousand dollars
for new constructions which means people
are buying up houses at massive premiums
which is it's making it so middle-class
working-class and
uh lower class people can't buy houses
because rich people are desperately
trying to get out of the dollar
and buy houses they think are going to
be undervalued and then joe biden says
we want to print several trillion
dollars again
and a petition now says 2.3 million
signatures at change.org says
print another 2 000 per person stimulus
because that's good news for the economy
but hey at the same time the media is
saying everything's a-okay
so we're we're going to get into all
this stuff obviously we have some stuff
to talk about with without you
we can make fun of cnn because their
ratings ratings are in the gutter and
they're obsessed with trump and they
know they're obsessed with trump and
don lemon is complaining about how
they're obsessed with trump while they
still talk about trump
talk about a boring thing to talk about
at this point but anyway we're going to
talk about it and we're hanging out with
uh uh
freedom tunes free freedom tunes i'm
back ladies and gentlemen happy to be
here
this is going to be an exciting show
very pumped about the
the news we're getting here about the
economy sounds great i trust the media
yeah well so the media is saying the
economy is on fire and economies
fire comma ian yes yes uh also the
internet is has been knocked out out
here i guess because there's like a
storm or something
bad so uh whatever we record this and it
goes up on itunes and spotify
so hey how about you uh just give us a
good review but anyway yeah sheamus is
here that's right lydia and i almost
died earlier
how bad the storm was driving back from
waffle house and it was
it was coming down so unbelievably hard
we could barely see
in front of us it was actually
terrifying it was one of those like
sideways
rains so bad it looked like a tornado
for a second you know yeah we can get
those warnings out here
yeah yeah and i saw a cow floating by
yeah oh
boy yeah but that was that was the cow
of its own volition yeah
ian's got a crystal ball yeah i do yeah
and i'm thinking top of it you know
lumber might be
expensive but now maybe is the time to
build a geodesic dome is your house
that doesn't take wood right you could
do it without wood yeah interesting
yeah every time i see a lumber truck on
the road now i'm like
i could i'm going to get rocks i could
retire right now
i'm here in the corner pushing buttons
as well uh seamus how much
uh remember i did that voice for you on
that one uh episode how much did you owe
me
oh no dude we're not having this
conversation right now dude there's like
seven episodes tim has done voices for
that i've not paid him for
yet the check is in the mail i keep
sending the invoices
with the ad revenue we don't do a huge
amount with crowd uh funding so yeah
please purchase one of these shirts to
help us
people may not realize this but uh
sheamus does all of his freedom tunes on
paper
yes on paper he has uh paints
watercolors yeah and then
he takes a picture with his with his
smartphone and just you know takes a
picture of each and every one
it's not a smartphone it's an it's an
old nokia but yeah basically and then i
text it to myself
yeah and then he puts it into he puts it
into uh some some free
unit linux software to just render it
all as a single video
exactly it's real that's why it looks as
good as it does that's true you get that
fantastic charming uh
style no i'm kidding that's fraud tim
people are gonna buy these t-shirts on
false pretenses
well how about instead they go to
timcast.com and send me become members
by clicking the members only button and
you'll get access to the exclusive
members only area
of the website yesterday we talked about
the secret wars conspiracy theory and
then we did like
a whole trump fan fiction thing where
he's like fighting flying a fighter jet
and like natalie portman jumps out and
like lands in
in on an iranian tanker it was really
fun that sounds fantastic
for inviting me you guys that's really
cool i'm glad i was here yeah
part of part of the story is that brie
larson was uh recruited early on but
betrayed us to the ccp
stealing the genesis delays from iran to
give to the xi jinping to make him
immortal
yeah if you want to hear that story go
to timcast.com and become a member
and you can waste your time listening to
it but at least you'll laugh here's the
thing if you want to become a member it
should be to watch the after show that
i'm going to be on jack's a good guy but
i wasn't there in the last episode which
means it's going to be significantly
less entertaining because my friends
just ditched me
well the after show for the bonus
segment for this one is going to be the
uh fouchy fan fiction and it's also
going to be just him beating me with the
two by four that he has because he
purchased america let everybody know uh
the whole hour before we're starting the
show when we're setting up it's just
me and sheamus doing various versions of
alex jones and
anthony fauci
droplet getting you dropped and that was
it was just us saying masks and droplets
droplets everyone's laughing no the
funniest was when uh sheamus was singing
numa numa as jordan peterson oh my gosh
what does it mean it's like we have to
actually analyze this well first of all
there's some people who claim that it's
an entirely separate
language like these gibberish words
actually mean
something in a different country the
economy is on fire
is that good or bad i don't know this
guy's talking here talking here about
jordan peterson it's complicated man
like is he
like hard times create strong men so
maybe it's not the worst thing in the
world yeah all right all right everybody
go to timcast.com become members and
then you can hear this nonsense at 11
the private sector uh freedom
what i told people was like everyone's
freaking out people i knew and i'm like
listen listen
like here's the bottom right i'm like
right here and you're here and the
market crashes and i'm like i don't know
yep i don't know what's going on you
know what i mean like more equal to
everyone and that's how socialism works
that's right the very very bottom we
went around because
everybody was cheering when it happened
i i don't remember it even until like
2011. do you guys remember like the
fallout didn't seem to start to
to rumble until like 2010 or 2011 what
do you mean like the
it just became a big deal like the fact
that we bailed out all these banks
established all this debt didn't seem to
like shock people until
a couple of years later yeah it was this
weird thing you started to see these
populist movements spring up on the
right and left you had occupy wall
street you also had the tea party
and the establishment was clearly very
threatened by them i remember there was
this show the newsroom which was always
putting forward the the pc narrative in
their stories and they had
an arc where the character was like
horribly intimidated by the tea party he
was a brave journalist for criticizing
them as if like no one on tv was doing
that it was hilarious how
how horribly um they were and how hard
they were
trying to make the tea party these
villains
i remember that it was heroic they still
do that today they're like oh this
person holds this
this brave courageous revenant idea that
trump is bad yeah that's really
revolutionary that i'm really impressed
as an as an aside for those that are
listening we're experiencing internet
troubles yes
so i just switched to one of our backups
because i guess like internet across the
board for our network is being hit
really hard it was a bit bad storm so i
switched
hopefully this one works it'll probably
reduce the resolution but we need to get
a power cable to charge because it's
just going through my phone
okay yeah hopefully that works what do
you have usb
c yeah yeah right here here yeah
is it long enough yeah i think so there
you go let's go
so that means fewer people are going to
see this so we can talk about more
controversial things
or or our feelings that's just our deep
feelings let's talk about legalizing
hemp
because if the if the wood industry if
the lumber industry really is going
spying
interesting well let's let's show this
check this out you want to talk about
market crash we got this uh this tweet's
going viral from brian nichols
says fyi and there's a big pile says
fall 2020 1 000
in lumber and you can see all of this
wood and they've painted the ends of
them blue
and then next to it says may 2021 one
thousand dollars in lumber
dude that's nuts uh for those that are
listening it's basically like
a tenth that's crazy yeah
one quarter i haven't been able to fact
check this at all but i've heard that it
was had something to do with trump's um
tariffs so that they the canadian lumber
won't they won't ship it down here
because it's too expensive i don't
believe it that's interesting yeah i
couldn't find anything i don't believe
it
so we had um uh when we had joe canton
he was talking about pacific northwest
and timbering and all that
and us regulations making it very
difficult to you know
source wood in the united states i i i
just don't believe it i don't trust the
media
when whenever they come out and they're
like you know donald trump did this it's
bad i'm like i don't believe you that's
like what wouldn't they blame him for
yeah it's the boy who cried wolf i'm
sure some of this is his fault right but
like
when you label everything as being the
result of trump's failures and it's like
we're not going to
believe you right he actually is brian
stelter could be sitting in a room with
don lemon and he could fart and then
look at him
first of all if i farted it would be
much louder it would be the
greatest fart you ever heard yes so
lumber
this means houses are going to spike
yeah it means that's paper so it's good
at 19 000
to the average cost of a house right now
it's gonna have a major ripple effect
check this out
so hold on a minute right we got food
shortages already we got beef and
chicken and a lot of people keep saying
like whenever we talk about this they're
like tim there's no shortage i'm like
okay well we ain't getting it
there's reports as a trucker shortage
and people are like there's not there's
triggers all over the place i'm like
okay well they're not
people some for some reason people
aren't driving yeah gas shortages food
whatever
chlorine i don't know weird stuff yeah
it's kind of weird so think about it
this way
somebody's got to do a job there's a lot
of jobs that require wood that's why
people go buy wood all the time
so i was talking to these these guys
that i know they built skate parks and i
asked them about like hey what's going
on like what have you seen and they
basically told me it's really bad right
now and so here's what i'm worried about
these guys are gonna go to their clients
and be like hey you know normally we do
these
these events and it costs a hundred
thousand dollars to build the park
okay well now it's gonna cost five
hundred thousand dollars to build the
park and the event is going to be like
no that's literally our entire budget
we still got a higher labor labor we got
to rent space we can't do it
we'd have to charge 200 per ticket
instead of you know 20 dollars
or or 40 so they say okay we're not
doing it
events get cancelled this exacerbates
the labor shortage
it means that without the raw materials
to do the work there's a ripple effect
it's not just the wood that you can't
buy it's the it's the construction jobs
it's the jobs that those job that money
goes and circulates too so sandwich
shops
yeah it's it's the events that we're
going to hire the contractors to build
the thing for them in the first place
that now can't do it
think about like like show not this is
brutal
well when you live in the middle of
nowhere welcome back everyone
yeah to the hottest of the hot that's
right awesome let's try satellite
we're just gonna we're going to our
third internet option right now backing
it up for satellite
maybe we'll get a little bit more of a
fluid uh vibration that way
we love to actually recover plastic
digestive and recovered plastic
so why do you think this isn't being
done right now because the
copper industry has a huge monopoly on
the system right now
and obviously the lumber industry you
can see william randolph hearst amongst
others
you know tree magnets they want to they
don't want hemp to be legal
randall hurst actually tried to get
people to make it illegal because
um and competing with his i was going to
say
literally literally that's literally
what we're doing
anywhere competition back in the 20s and
30s
uh and then what other materials are are
up for obviously the petroleum industry
the steel industry which is like the
coal industry
dude it all ripples and so they keep
saying it's like oh supply just needs to
catch up it's like bro nobody wants to
work
exactly no but nobody's working any i i
just got i got a bunch of these stories
but look at this one pbs
are unemployment benefits keeping
americans home
oh look at the labor shortage and it's
from yesterday does just paying
people not to do something stop them
from doing it this is the problem with
leftist media is that
the right was talking about this months
ago yeah
last year thomas massey and some
republicans were like hey don't pay
people not to work
it was a bad idea yeah now pbs is like
that's that's how you destroy your
economy
it's incredible from it yeah the entire
unemployment industry is based on like
here we'll pay you
is if but if you start working again
we're going to cut off your benefits
yeah exactly it's horrible what the heck
right so when you're getting 16 what
what are they going to pay
this is you know what's creepy we were
trying to uh we were trying to order
food here the other day
and a bunch of the restaurants were just
closed for no reason oh yep i'm like
i'm pretty sure wednesday is at memorial
day you know what i mean like memorial
day was monday
tuesday they were closed wednesday of
their close and i'm like did people just
not show up yep
so we so it was funny because we ordered
food and then it defaulted for today
because for no reason the restaurant was
closed the other day and i guess
you know no one noticed and so when you
clicked order it just defaulted for the
next availability
that's annoying yeah yeah yeah yeah food
arrived today yeah we had it was
delicious
that works out you know shut up and i'm
like okay so i guess they reopened i was
worried that they were going to be like
permanently closed or something
maybe it's just people wanted a longer
long weekend you know it definitely
would probably coincide with not having
a lot of customers too
i would think because most businesses
wouldn't shut her for three days for
memorial day unless they were
not dude i can't have employees though i
mean if people aren't showing up
i don't have a choice yeah you drive
around looking at these restaurants and
they're just like
offering crazy amounts of money oh yeah
the the waffle house had a sign
like we are fighting the pancake
patriarchy please apply here and i will
promote women more i'm not kidding yeah
we'll promote women
you said pancake patriots yes the
pancake patriarchy i was like you know
what i'm not
eating here this is ridiculous yeah
that's creepy but they they were trying
to push
uh social justice yeah yeah it was like
using social justice stuff but to try to
get people to work there was very
strange
yeah because the people with college
degrees are the people who are gonna be
working
seriously it's true oh my goodness
you're right
man wow that's brutal that that's mean
to the waffle house
yeah honestly no in all honesty yes like
the people at waffle house
like work pretty hard yeah you know
that's true yeah
that's not that's what i'm saying like i
i think most uh college students in the
liberal arts field
or not yeah wouldn't like survive at a
job seriously
absolutely well you got to pay your back
your loans you know that's true yeah and
if your love of theater is
strong enough you gotta do it somehow
i've been there so what do we do
uh we got this story from from uh
business insider warren buffett's
favorite market indicator hits 200
signaling stocks are overpriced and a
crash may be coming well that's almost
like they just
flooded the market with liquidity
without really thinking about the
long-term effects it does seem like that
yeah i mean
i wonder if they were thinking about the
long-term effects do you look at the
things that have been hit beef and gas
yeah i don't know lies i really think
they just
look for these band-aids to slap onto
things and
they hope they'll be able to figure
something out later i don't think it's
intentional i don't think they're trying
to destroy it i think they're just
unbelievably short-sighted
make sense yeah i'll say the other day
that it's like the solution is
exacerbating the problem
they don't they don't know what to do so
they're like the economy's on is in
flames and it's collapsing so just pump
more money and print more money like
exactly that's what most these countries
do when before hyper hyperinflation hits
yes the economy starts stagnating so
they print money and spend it they do
these big government spending packages
where they're like i know
if we print a bunch of money and then
spend it ourselves that will kick-start
the economy because then the people we
hire will buy stuff
and then you end up with trillion-dollar
bills yeah modern monetary policy they
did that after world war ii
they they invested in the infrastructure
though and were able to rebuild like
factories and things that
were actually did kickstart the economy
seemingly
but they didn't do that this time around
they just gave the money out did you
guys hear that russia
dumped uh like 45 billion us dollars
from one of their funds
what no russia's right they don't want
to uh i mean it's not like it's the most
amount of money in the world or whatever
that's 45 billion yeah they're selling
off
so if russia is trying to get off the
dollar and china's trying to get the
dollar
then china's using dollars for the belt
and road initiative i think uh
oh almost none of them too angela merkel
doesn't have any
macron doesn't have any a lot of these
leaders just have
they don't really care about the future
because they don't really care about
their kids
exactly there was that quote from john
maynard keynes when they asked him what
what a perfect person to bring up right
now right they asked him well what do we
do when we accumulate too much debt and
he said well in the long run we'll all
be dead
of course john maynard keynes never had
any children so of course he had that
attitude
but it's funny you can really tell how
optimistic after i graduated college and
he was asking uh people around my age
are you up an optimist or a pessimist oh
i'm an optimist blah blah blah
are you gonna have kids i don't know if
i could bring my kids into this world
it's like okay well then you're a
pessimist yeah and it's just interesting
like you said all these foreign leaders
don't have children or if they do they
have a very small family i think it's
because they don't have a whole lot of
faith in the future
does putin have a family i think he does
yeah yeah
he does yeah he is there a video of like
him teaching his daughter to do like
yeah
how to interfere in elections you send
ballots to this
first you have non-state actors buy 46
000
worth of facebook ads she's like she's a
little kid and she reaches over to press
enter and she looks at him and he like
nods at her and then she presses enter
and then says like facebook ad purchased
one ball and he's like oh
then you just see the electoral map
switch he's like yes good i'm so proud
of you
yes you're prepared what do you mean by
investing in yourself lydia hit the gym
get stronger eat right make yourself
i feel really targeted right now for a
snack
you know i'm right i've been working out
more lately
every everybody should be super ripped
wearing a red flannel and carrying
around an axe to chop down some trees
that's right and build a log cabin
that's what i'm saying
are we talking about jack murphy right
now no no no everyone women men
dogs we had a couple of trees at
tim's other house back in jersey and we
cut them down had them cut down and then
so we know there's wood in the backyard
so we're just kind of chopping wood you
know
so and wood is sharp it is it really is
and i tried a few times no one's ever
going to know because see this is they
just want the audience to know this is
why you guys have to tune in because
when you're not watching
we just lose our minds so one of our
chickens might be transgender
what really yeah what is it yeah i think
it's intersex if it's just
no no no what do you mean by transgender
like it's a real acting female it's a
it's a female that
is has become the male because there's
no mail she's uh and so the other night
we had
we had the fire department come out
because the alarm went off yeah that was
great nobody would take responsibility
for why it went on did it
because it probably happened like it was
four in the morning and the smoke alarm
went off drums
yeah and it was probably someone just
like doing something dumb
like trying to losing a lighter smoking
crack in the kitchen
baking potatoes who knows yeah and
everyone's like wasn't me it was me so
the only thing we can do is like we got
to call the fire department out because
it could be electrical fire right the
alarm's going off we got to do a full
suite
but anyone who came out the chickens you
know they all wake up and they all walk
out like all slow looking at what's
going on
and then one of the chickens started
crowing what and i was like what's this
noise
and then i looked over and i watched it
and they all stopped they'll stop and
just stare at me i'm like which one are
you
using
which was it what they did and then okay
and then i walk away and then i hear the
crowing again
so i walk over and i look again don't
see anything they won't tell you and
then
i walk away and then i turn around right
away and then there it is
it was roberta and she was robert
oh yeah so i looked it up and apparently
there's a thing that happens with one in
ten thousand chickens
where if there's no rooster that they're
at the top of the pecking order they
start acting like
like roosters and they do it because
they were alerting the
the hens to danger and so there's a
crazy thing that happens apparently
they only have one ovary and if it gets
infected or shuts down
they actually will lose their bodies
and grow like rooster plumage and then
start actually roosting and roostering
tim i don't need to hear this liberal
nonsense all right and this is like a
gender studies course i know
this is good uh this is actually more
like jurassic park in my mind life uh uh
uh finds a way somehow it's basically
what happens
because they reproduce anything no no it
has nothing to do with it i know i was i
was really i was kidding
just said there's no way that's insane
of like you know so before the show
starts we have like all of these
these topics lined up and then uh i
don't think anyone can hear because we
disable the
the the audio but i'm hearing uh
like every three seconds and i'm like i
can't i'm just i'm over it
yeah we're just we're hanging out we're
just gonna watch jurassic park let's
just do mystery science theater 3
000. we'll just watch them so we still
have some news we can talk about but uh
sheamus do jordan peterson it's like man
okay if you're going to ask me to do
jordan peterson the moment no one else
knows what to talk about all i have to
say is the man's work isn't so trivial
that it can be distilled into this
character conversation to have
because there's something wrong with the
internet man that's not how it works
it's like that's not fair to the man
that's really do it you know offensive
you know what's bugging me though we've
got
high speed very expensive internet we've
got standard cable landline internet
yeah
we have mobile wi-fi backup and
satellite and they are all down it was a
crazy storm
a multiple machines i don't know it's
like three in the afternoon too that's
what i was getting is there an internet
outage going on maybe somewhere let me
know i was
having some weird stuff with the
internet earlier when i was uploading my
video but okay
um speaking of roberta the chicken is
she the brown oh
hey hey there's there's a bunch of there
are some outages okay
yeah so uh it looks like discord
counter-strike call of duty steam paypal
uh all have big spikes hbo max has a
decent spike
it's not everybody but there's a decent
amount of services that are they're
reporting huge spikes and outages
call of duty and counter-strike it's not
like critical infrastructure there or
anything but i tell you
well that's your opinion until the
because people yeah gas prices
food all this yeah blah blah but if the
internet goes out
people are going to go crazy oh i will
be so relieved dude the internet goes i
don't have to do this anymore
i'm free tim how are people going to get
freedom toons t-shirts how are people
going to buy bitcoin
you know what i'm going to do what if
the internet just like just stopped
working
i would go i would go find some red
flannel and
an axe and then i'll just get some boots
and i just walk into the woods and be
like well i better start practicing
spend two years out because well because
everybody knows that in order to be
like actually to be able to survive it
starts with lumberjack yeah that's
exactly it you have to be a lumberjack
that's the only way
would you start with a small tree don't
work your way up or would you just look
for the biggest
hardiest no because you have to let the
small tree grow you're just wasting
it at one point i would rather supervise
seamus you do the work yeah i
i look listen i know what i'm talking
about here all right i'm an outdoorsman
i'm a survivalist
you're like a master lumberjack yes
basically
and i could go out there just give me i
don't even need an axe man i need like a
hatchet and a great
redwood and maybe like five ten minutes
people are just tuning in right now not
understanding the context about the
internet and they're like
is the internet working now yeah yeah
the internet's been out so it's just
it's cutting in and out
so it's just like you know we're
chilling yeah i'm sorry guys my back
hurts
oh really yeah were you working out
earlier no i think i pulled some
oh i went i went and bought an obscene
amount of guns that's fantastic i wish i
was invited but i was sleeping i was
napping well so so this is also
tim like sent me a text saying don't
come and i was asleep so i didn't get
it okay yeah yeah yeah we didn't want
him to come do you want to talk on the
specific
guns that you bought no i i mean i don't
even know it's just like she lost them
in a boat
walked in and i was like i was like all
of them please uh so what happened is
yeah i did buy a lot of guns um i i
texted crowder i'm like don't show
anyone this video
and he was like nice uh no so i i did
uh i think i i did a segment today
talking about like there was a brief
pause in money reporting
a lot of people are talking about the m2
money supply because remember that thing
where like the spike goes straight up
yeah
and people are saying like i i we've
talked about it quite like tim you're
wrong the m2 money supply they just
changed how it's reported
and i'm like did you read what it says
my understanding
i could be wrong again what they're
saying is that
savings accounts used to have
restrictions on how much you could
transfer out of the account and they
removed that because of covid
effectively turning savings account into
checkings account checking accounts
which made the money supply explode
because all of a sudden people could now
use their savings like really really
quickly so if you look at uh i'm sorry
that's m1 if you look at m2
the spike is less pronounced but there
is a big spike
and so i'm looking at all this i'm
looking at the story about you know
berkshire hathaway i'm looking at
amc stock just it's nuts like 75
yesterday i'm looking at dogecoin and
i'm like
bro joe biden wants well
let me see if i can let me see if i have
the story we'll pull up two trillion
dollars in taxes
but six trillion in spending and 22
trillion in
borrowing what can go wrong and i was
like
i should buy stuff yeah and i'm like
well what do you buy stock
no i mean crypto and land gold and
crypto i guess yeah copper
so i bought guns yeah guns are always
gonna be a good investment i'm sorry
but but but not because i'm like the
apocalypse is nigh
no i was actually thinking like if i buy
a car cars go down
exactly exactly i have some
cryptocurrency i have some gold and
silver
like what's a good thing that's
functional important so what did i get i
bought mouthwash
yes isopropyl alcohol and guns
because guns are are are like they're
machines they're simple machines they
work well and my worst case scenario is
like i just you know end up selling them
back to stores or something or just
have them and i think uh you know it'll
be fun to go to the range and we can
film videos and we can talk about
i look at it like the worst case
scenario for me i have these guns we can
just do vlogs where we're like
explaining with different kinds and
everything
and i'm just like i don't want to sit
here
and just have dollars that are
disappearing it was i'll tell you it was
really freaky because
we built this this the park does the
skatepark for the for the vlogs and the
shows and we're like trying to make this
big fun space
some people said it's like fantasy
factory or whatever and i was like i
want to make a big cultural thing
and i'm looking at the prices to do what
we already did we wouldn't be able to do
it right now geez
yeah and so i'm like so so so by sheer
nature of just
having money sit around i've lost the
ability to grow the business yeah yeah
so it's like i'm trying to figure out
what i'm going to hire hire a bunch of
people asap
just hire everybody like you're hired i
don't know yeah i'd rather have the
person here doing backflips and
cartwheels in the front lawn than just
having money disappeared yeah
then the problem is as the uh as the
dollar inflates it becomes more and more
expensive to keep all the people you
just hired
that's a good point i mean well if
like what like the food will get too
expensive yeah like their cost of living
is going to increase a lot
yeah i know then i'll just build you
know like uh the tim compound fun fact
no
we'll get we'll we'll get maybe like a
couple hundred square feet but we'll
make
you know stand-up sleeping rooms so we
can fit 300 people follow the closets
what we'll do is we'll get sleeping bags
that hang
so you you you climb in and zip up and
just hang
and you don't need space that's smart
it's time to wake up to come in and
hit it who needs privacy yeah we'll just
put them all against the wall in fact
we'll double
out we'll double them up just use
plastic bags there's a lot of cicadas
out eat the bugs
the front of your sleeping bag has
another hook to hang another person on
the sleeping bag
yeah yeah have like a little kangaroo
pouch dude we're all gonna get real
close huh
people should get out of cities man if
you can that's a good a good a good
really good idea yeah i think i'm gonna
do that
like i go outside you know there's like
there's like an egg like i walk into the
chicken thing it's like an egg
i just take it and i'm like i wash it
off and i eat it that's true in my city
too but i live in a very
southern city you know just eggs what a
city so i'm just i i don't want to dox
myself
whoa smart stuff so the cicadas are
getting crazy
they're like at first they're on the
trees and they're they're they all
scream have you ever heard them
it's their wings i hear they're they're
flapping their wings so fast it sounds
like they're snowing no no no no no no
they're actually screaming i don't know
if they're actually screaming but there
was one flying above me
and it wasn't noisy and then when i went
to swat it went right up
and i was like wow yeah that happened
dude one of them landed on me and then i
was like get off me and i like blew on
it and i was like
oh my gosh it was terrible
uh i got i have this thing called the
bug assault
yeah pump action salt blaster for bugs
and so what happens is cicada when it
like flies at me
i take its wing out and then toss it
into the chickens
so so i basically been harvesting
cicadas from the air to give to the
chickens chickens are going us they're
eating them all up
when tim said he bought a bunch of guns
that's what he was talking about a bunch
of salt
shots nerf that's what i call an assault
weapon
so the thing about the cicadas is we had
those in the area i grew up i grew up
right outside chicago
and we got that i think we're about two
years different from you guys with the
17-year cycle
but the ground was like black it was
just covered in cicadas it was worse
than it was here
they were everywhere i saw a photo from
loudoun county
and it was a bush with every leaf was
just covered in cicadas like it was like
a bush but it was brown
and i was like would it be great to like
throw a net over that catch them all and
throw them into a chicken coop
just eat them just eat the bugs don't
don't why not
what's wrong with it tastes terrible
i've heard yeah i somebody told me that
one of their friends they were i think
uh
somebody here was telling me that their
boyfriend ate one and that it tasted
disgusting no delicious you should try
it leave you you should try it no it's
really good do it on air
no now we're talking you got to grind it
up and put it
out we're talking about like and soak in
it why don't you make cicada bread
i don't want to i will i will i just
like that we made cricket they were
farmed crickets
they were farmed fried and milled the
the cicadas are like dude they're out of
the ground in like the middle of nowhere
there's going to be like
weird parasites and they have that they
have that new that well i'll tell you
this they have some kind of like fungus
disease
that i think they're they're now they
have psilocybin in them or something
like that oh my gosh did you guys see
that do you hear something like that i
did
yeah what is this whoa dude people going
on yeah so they're getting this fungus
and it makes them go crazy and they
become
even more um insane about
having cicada babies and they start
shaking really really really really
really fast and they basically like
implode
their butts fall off yeah uh have you
confirmed that it's psilocybin
no ian's like i want to eat them now
[Laughter]
i'm looking into it no it's it is some
form of hallucinogenic
fungus though which is really
interesting so wait a minute next thing
we know like in the backyard
[Laughter]
that'd be interesting are you guys
familiar with ergot yeah yeah
yeah lsd comes in yeah they they
synthesized it out of
ergotamine lsd is synthesized out of
ergotomy which is the function
yeah yeah and like they say the salem
witchcraft trials they went insane
because they were getting ergot
poisoning and they didn't know
so they thought everybody was like and
all these things in the past have been
attributed to it like the dancing
guess their um private parts fall off
because they get moving too
the fungus is called massive picture
masospora is the name of the fungus
you gotta research it for us this is
really curious
and amphetamine all right let me read we
got we got from npr they say after 17
years underground the brood x periodical
cicadas are slowly emerging in 15 states
yeah we know they'll shed their skins
and spend four to six weeks mating
before the female lay eggs and then they
all die
but some of them are getting wilder a
fungus called masospora
which can produce compounds of cathinone
and amphetamine
infects a smallness so their uppers dude
infects a small number of them and makes
them lose control
it takes over their bodies causing them
to lose their lower abdomen
and genitals and it pushes their mating
and hyperdrive but they don't have junk
how they can do it
this is stranger than fiction matt
cassin an associate professor of
forest pathology and mycology at west
virginia university tells npr's all
things considered
to have something that's being
manipulated by a fungus to be hyper
sexual
and have prolonged stamina and just mate
like crazy
kassadin has been studying masospora for
about five years says just before the
cicadas rise on the ground the spores of
the fungus start to infect the bug
once it's above ground it starts to shed
its skin become an adult his book falls
off
then a white plug of fungus grows in its
place
oh nasty that's no fun it looks like the
backside of cicada is being replaced
either by chalk
or by like one of the nubby middle
school erasers
the insects have no idea what's
happening the fungus however is pulling
the strings and making skaters want to
mate with everyone
males that are infected will continue to
mate with females but they'll also
pretend to be
female so they can spread the fungus to
males what it's turning
it's a bug this fungus is turning to
freaking cicadas
i don't like them putting fungus in the
cicadas
dude how come this stuff doesn't happen
to people i'm not that upset about it
i think it does but i don't i don't have
fomo about that
it's more subtle with people like our
bacteria our gut biome is kind of
pulling the strings of our behavior you
know eat food then you get cravings
that's like mind control
um but you see it real blatant in some
animals like where the
the fungus infects the brain of the worm
and then it like or the bug and then the
bug starts going crazy like zombie bug
you guys wanna hear something real gross
yeah so uh we've got cicadas all over
the place
you know what i mean and i've been
telling the story about like i catch
them right you know the easiest way
the easiest way for me has been to get
cicadas for the chickens i don't know
i just walk to the parking lot and pick
them up you know why because the parking
lot is it's blacktop we got it sealed
and so in the middle of the day when the
sun hits it and the ground is so hot you
can't walk on it oh the cicadas will
land
and then just burn to death oh nice
they'll just die
and so i walk up and they're just like
freaking out and i just pick them up and
throw the chicken thing and the chickens
eat a warm meal
but today i came out cause i can't get
them all some have melted to the
pavement oh no oh that's wrong
brutal nature is mad well it's not i
wouldn't isn't nature i mean we're the
ones who put the black ops
but what i mean we come from nature too
you know like we have an agent that's
true
maybe maybe blacktop is inhumane in
general
you know it's all tickers of death the
crazy thing about it is their butts
like are they fall off and then the
fungus grows out of it could you imagine
like if human beings
like got infected and their butts fell i
couldn't i don't want to
you know hold on hold on hold on hold on
just cheer me out
a bunch of dudes their butts fall off
and is replaced by weird
spongy fungal spores and then they just
become
like zombie crazed and start pretending
to be women like trying to
spread the fungus maybe that's what the
cicadas are doing maybe it has happened
in the past and there was a war
and they had to kill fungus butts
they're like hey fungus butt
bro the last of these hold on hold on
so you know there's like the last of us
where it's like the mushrooms take over
them no i haven't seen
it they got to do this they got to make
it it's like fungus butt
oh my god yeah the zombies are like
people like i want to do it and they're
like their butts are fungus spores
no fun no
so on the unemployment benefits
don't eat cicadas yeah dude how many
people do you think ate one of these
infected cicadas oh
oh man i don't know is this oh no no
i will not people are eating bats
they're eating cicadas how many
pandemics are we gonna have to have
people eating strange things dude what
if like it does spread to humans because
somebody saw the news about eating
cicadas
like that would actually be a crazy uh
like video game prime people are all
like
fungus but zombies and it's like in the
year 2021
the media told everyone to eat cicadas
out of the ground
but they were infected and the fungus
spread to humans
how many people do you think actually
ate cicadas oh there's a restaurant
nearby that does it
what yeah it's good really
yeah where do they farm them they the
guy walks outside his backyard and pulls
them off to pull them off the buildings
could you imagine that could you imagine
like
i'd like to go get food and the guy's
like oh just a minute he lifts this up
lifts a stone off the ground and pulls
grubs and garbage out of the ground and
just tucks it in a pan dude
he's like just coming right up i'd be
like no i'm good dude
if i wanted to eat the bugs off the
ground i just do it myself bro this is
what the lion king was trying to program
us towards
the entire reason disney released that
propaganda film trying to make us like
timon and pumbaa yeah because they were
telling somebody
eat the bugs yeah because because you
know simba was supposed to eat them
yeah exactly they're like like hold on
have you thought about bugs
and they're like oh it's so good and
he's like okay and eats bugs
no they were sincere though they
actually ate bugs before that they were
bug eaters you could tell they enjoyed
it too much when they introduced simba
to the concept of eating bugs
but but yes that hog in a meerkat they
eat bugs okay
yeah exactly but i'm saying they weren't
being insincere they were like yeah
like you really should eat this and we
enjoy it they weren't being yeah you
know
they actually enjoyed it this wasn't
like a long con i have uh uh are you
ready for the
the post-apocalyptic dollar collapse
market crash
zombie butt eat the bugs future i don't
know that
like ready is ever a word i could use to
describe my state with respect to that
but i'm preparing
how are you preparing uh you know i've
got some i've got some emergency food
i've got
some uh got some weapons i've got some
fungal spray
oh i'm not sure what else fungal spray
i'm coming to your house yeah you know
commune like a literal commune
after the apocalypse and antifa shows up
and they're like this is horrible we'd
like to no no they're like we'd like to
come in
like uh excellent um well uh what could
you contribute to the community
we can smash your buildings and make
everyone question the
the social order of your the delegate
the delicate fabric of your society
uh in a post-apocalyptic scenario um
intriguing intriguing
and what will the benefit of this be no
benefit will just destroy your way of
life
and racism that's communist racism
we'll end will end the racism of you
yeah and your and your and your commune
yeah i think it'd be funny because like
they would contribute literally nothing
literally nothing we saw that with chop
remember that garden chop i'm sorry chaz
chop i don't know
no goes on i don't know what the
preferred term is but yeah
no go zone yeah the no-go zone where
they have the the little garden thing
that they set up yeah
on top of cardboard they uh see they're
they're breaking down george square
george oh yeah we'll pull that up let's
do that yeah about that the chop
wait what happened they're pulling down
that memorial george floyd memorial
where there's like 12 city blocks where
they like blocked off uh from the road
no no no
it's okay here we go is this bunk uh
it's not a bunk it's just you're you're
late to the party
yes so cbs4 minnesota says george floyd
square intersection briefly reopened
before
community pushback you know man
are we still on the air okay i'm not
going to swear i was going to swear if i
came and just put it all back
oh and then they come back again to take
it down again
no that's it they gave up oh yeah the
police are are you know incapable of
doing anything
damn well they can arrest you yeah you
know for at a moment's notice based on
governor uh government edict
yeah but not antifa based on the actual
law yeah
so i do i have a question about this you
know let me ask you a question so uh
uh sheamus what would you call it if a
group of people
of an ideology they they uh uh
believe your nation's history is fake
and they begin imposing their ideology
over this people
they fly a different flag they burn the
flag of the one nation
they start seizing territory in certain
cities where people are literally shot
and killed
and they get they get the law
enforcement to operate based on their
whims
and edict instead of the actual law
those that literally break
hard law are exempt from it and those
who violate edict
get arrested and put in jail meanwhile
prisoners are being released
and then they then fly their flag at
your embassy like what would you call
that
mostly peaceful mostly peaceful mostly
peaceful yeah i think that's probably a
solid situation you add all those things
together
wrong with that tim they're protesting a
bad thing so
anything they do is okay and if you
criticize any of that you're just okay
with the bad thing that they're probably
let's go through this uh let's go let's
literally go through each point first
antifa openly breaks the law and the
da's release them
actual statutory law that is codified
yep
conservatives and people and and you
know not necessarily even conservative
small business owners
violate edict from governors that is not
codified and they get arrested by police
and fined yep
okay antifa begins seizing different
jurisdictions of different cities
with weapons and even killing people on
numerous occasions
these people say that the history of
this nation is incorrect
everyone of this this nation is evil and
they burn and desecrate the flag of this
nation
and then they fly their own flag
with marxist symbols at the embassies of
this nation
that doesn't it sounds like uh like in
like insurrection like occupation
like like insurrection like a group of
people telling you your history is wrong
and burning your flag
like you're flying their flag at your
embassy if it was the chinese government
i hate
i don't want to like make the chinese
bad guys you know whatever but if it was
like a foreign powers government that
was doing this to our country
that's that that would be like an
occupation and creating like a puppet
state out of our government yep
if they can decide who who is or isn't
guilty of the crimes
but it was like the chinese government
or the government was deciding that's
in west virginia there's a huge
controversy happening because
at the schools the people who are uh
like
who got elected are woke and they're
introduced she gets arrested
she gets arrested and locked up you look
at the barber in in michigan
broke no law violated the decree of a
governor
yeah dude if when a group of people come
to you and say your history is fake
and they demand you revise your history
and they go into your schools without
telling your kids
that their history is wrong and that the
the you know
the people who run this country are evil
the founding fathers are evil that the
country is an
evil nation that must be you know broken
up or broken apart they burn the flag
the police help them i'm like that's it
like america what is it
is it still a thing at this point when
the history of this country has been
erased as the country still exists
is there an america if the history of
america is gone it's an interesting
question i mean we talked about this
before but the cities are definitely
gone i would say
go out to the country get away from them
you've been saying that a lot too
i think it's possible that this country
could just end up fracturing
i see secession being a possibility that
sounds kind of insane i think if you
said that five years ago people would
look at you funny
and i'm not saying it's a certainty but
it certainly
seems possible at this point and i think
maybe
that could be the only peaceful solution
maybe again and i'm also mostly peaceful
i'm also more or less thinking out loud
here i'm not making hard in fast
predictions but
still have a country i think it's just
that these cities end up falling to
these
far less actives or what happens is
after some time people realize how
horrible things have gotten in the areas
where these activists have basically
been put in charge by the political
authorities
and they they react against it
i just i just see it for people who burn
the american flag and now they're flying
their flag at our embassies for sure
for sure i guess my point is i i think
there's going to be a massive backlash
against it
i don't no no i think conservatives are
particularly ineffective
yes so i agree that conservatives are
but i think a lot of the people who buy
into this stuff right now
are starting to see it fall apart and
the more power we give them
the more they're going to be exposed is
completely incompetent
even evil to their followers i
but it's tribalism maybe i mean i think
it's tribalism but like at some point
you know when you're not getting fed you
kind of stop believing in whatever it is
the people who are in charge of you are
telling you the narrative
except one faction is saying we'll give
you everything for free and it's those
evil evil people keeping it from you so
when things break down they're going to
look at two factions the republicans
being like work hard
and then they're going to look at the
democrats being like we'll give you
whatever you want
and who wh wh where are they going to
flock to i guess depends on how things
actually become divided in terms of the
actual authority
if you look at these left-wing cities
where people are protesting and they're
getting away with doing whatever they
want and they're
essentially in charge to some extent
like you've said they basically can run
wild and do as they please
i think it's going to become obvious
even if people in these movies had
wheeler gets reelected
they everyone hated him even the left
hated him and he still gets reelected
and then you look at minnesota and you
look what they did with the chauvin
trial
i mean dude i have zero faith
that this country like i look at
everything that's happening and i'm like
the people who are ignoring it they're
going to wake up one day not realize
what happened or how it happened because
when you're watching it happen in real
time
you can it's just crazy but it's really
funny
when i when i talk to somebody who's who
doesn't pay attention to the news
and they still think it's 2019. they're
like man last year was crazy huh
and then i'll be like what about it was
crazy and they'll be like you know just
pandemic on the lockdown
and you can ask them anything about the
stimulus the inflation the shortages the
pipeline attacks
you could talk to them about china and
taiwan also be like what
it's really crazy when i look someone in
the eyes and i'm like yes what did you
think about like
you know they're flying blm flags at our
embassies and they go
what yeah i'm like what
like it's it's insane how cause it's
imagine this
if imagine if right now you hear this
stuff
and then you should turn the news off
and the next time i see you i'll be like
so did you report to your gulag for uh
reassignment
for for education for gender
reassignment they'd be they'd be like
what are you talking about it's like
oh yeah education starts tomorrow and
they're like what do you what that's
that's not real how can that be real
and it's and it's been this way
throughout the culture war when i talk
to people who don't follow
news i'll say something and they'll just
be like that's not true how is that
possible
yeah because it's happening faster and
faster and faster
so we're at this point now where let's
talk about uh well the state of this
country
a year of riots and explosions and
vandalism and chaos in the pacific
northwest
the no-go zones being set up where
people are taking them over with guns
and killing people literally killing
them in the george floyd no-go zone
in the capitol hill no-go zone people
literally being shot and killed in
portland air and dance and getting shot
in the chest
then you look at the trial of chauvin
and what happens not only does he get
charged by the state the feds come in
after the fact and the feds had a secret
plan to arrest him should he have been
acquitted
and now they're charging him again with
civil rights violations and the three
other cops
when he was being tried the jury had to
be escorted in
with armed security because the city was
under a riot
so you know that's not a fair trial 100
like i said the embassy is flying the
flags of this ideology
joe biden reversing a ton of trump
policies on banning the ideology
it really does feel like if you took
someone from two years ago
and brought them to today they would not
believe a word you would say about the
current state of the country
and believe it or not many people still
don't think antifa exists well you know
and this is the thing so when people
were talking about the far
left for for the past several years we
were more or less scoffed at
as not serious because this is just a
bunch of young dumb college students and
teenager young adult activists no one
actually cares they don't have any
actual power and look at where they are
now
everywhere yeah 16 year olds are 19 year
olds now yeah
yeah and the 18 year olds are you know
in their 20s
and the people in their 20s are now
entering their there's civil war
like the collapse is going to get crazy
when you see people
fleeing get power and basically tear
down the institutions that they
harbor resentment towards for whatever
reason but they're doing it on a postman
yeah i just i think that it's
possible at the other on the other hand
i don't know um i think
the entire dominant media culture is on
their side
and that's no small thing i think many
americans don't trust the media anymore
but some still do and also these people
are in control of the social media
outlets as well and so they
determine what's true and false and the
fact checkers will say x y and z if it
fits their
agenda and so it's hard for me to say
i can't say right now that there will
absolutely be this backlash by
2024 and that donald trump will be
re-elected but i do think that it's a
distinct possibility
there are a lot of factors here and it's
too complicated to make one
prediction i want to sort of see how
things go especially because look
if you had asked me one year or less
than one year into trump's presidency
what i thought the end of his first term
would look like none of my predictions
would have come remotely close to what
ended up happening
and so right now we're less than a year
and a biden's president i'm supposed
presidency and i'm kind of sitting here
trying to make a prediction
by 2024 if things will get bad enough i
mean i really can't
we just have to expect the unexpected at
this point and pray i mean that's my
only advice
i don't know if he'll get reelected i
mean it might be a buchanan situation
you know joe biden flounders and then
trump gets re-elected and then civil war
or whatever
but uh i will say that the left has been
completely unopposed
i think it was jessie kelly maybe it was
just a killing somebody said that the
left won the culture war because they're
the only ones fighting it
there's truth in that and like michael
malus says i know he gets a shout out
every other episode here but the
difference between the left and the
right is the left is serious
yep that's it you got a bunch of zealots
who will do anything they say by any
means necessary yeah violent psychopaths
burning down buildings smashing things
and
you get the republican party like don't
you do that yeah
yeah one thing i was mentioning the
other day is that nancy pelosi comes out
and screams january 6 and what do the
republicans come back and say
january 6th instead of coming out and
saying antifa
that's they don't do it you guys
endorsed this times
20 all summer long more than times 20.
um people were rioting and literally
burning down this country for months
straight and we were told that that was
mostly peaceful and it was a-okay
the republican party is uh a is
subservient to the democratic party
period
hands down 100 percent all of them every
single one
even with a few exceptions oh you really
didn't you're going to rand paul
paul made the brianna taylor bill that
is the left one why
is there no david dorn bill why
why is there no one standing up and
demanding a national holiday or making
us think about it
and i know you mentioned the media but
that's that's not relevant
when even rand paul comes out and says
you're framing your rules here's my
proposition
they are subservient to the democrats
period yeah i was saying that
the media tempers the the flame it
basically heats up the metal
to get the iron hot so that you can as a
politician strike it and be like i want
to make a bill about
this topic because this the media has
made it such a hot
ready to be molded topic and that
david dorn thing there wasn't enough
public knowledge about the guy
trump had the opportunity to do so much
he never did i know
even though trump was a fighter he still
would give the interviews to these
organizations acting as though they were
neutral
arbiters of anything they weren't
they're they're it's all for the
political agenda
so even during all of this you can force
the press to cover stories
okay and and republicans never do
they always bow down to the narrative
from the left
so that's it is it just because they
don't have the contacts in the
in the media organizations or the
organizations because they're not
serious
because they're just old they're not not
all of them are old collecting a
paycheck
you're right not all this is not serious
look i mean
you get um marjorie taylor green and she
pushes back much in the way that um
many of the democrats do like the squad
especially
and they hate her for it there you go
you got a fighter there
lauren bobert pushes back still though
almo
i would say maybe marjory taylor green
is the only one who's not playing into
their narrative and is
actually pushing back and saying you
know i counter this but almost all the
republicans just say whatever it is the
democrats narrative is they argue
on their terms there you go the unit
party
i think no no no it's it's the the
neocons joined the democrats a long time
ago yeah
yeah bill crystal basically it was
during obama's
reign uh that they went over and and got
on his drone bomb
and and the remaining republicans are
just like
oh you know there's no leaders there's
no leadership not in not in our
government not really no the democrats
have leaders
tons of them they do yeah absolutely how
do you define a leader
uh they say they they they take action
they command they demand
it's like follow aoc yeah aoc can i
also can come out say whatever she wants
and it becomes major news right
she becomes the story right ted cruz
goes on vacation and then runs back
cowering like i'm so sorry i was
just flying my daughter i'm so sorry i
don't think
regarding what we were talking about
earlier about is there a way like how do
i
is there a way out of this i think that
i don't see it
that people could refocus the problem
onto
the the banking industry and realize
that they're printing us into madness
republicans all say oh it was bad oh
we're so sorry
and then you get some republicans who
are clearly democrats saying like my
colleagues won't even say the right
thing and then even the ones who are
saying it's political and to ignore it
are still
bringing it up and making it the center
focus interesting
yeah so they're walking right and it's
like they're
they're playing they're fighting an
alligator underwater man i know
it's uh i think maybe not talking but
talking about politics one thing but
like trying to
trying to fix the system by using that
is fighting the alligator underwater
like trying to use the political
establishment
to fix the political establishment is
just not the place to do it
there's no tact there's no tact there's
no strategy no
we need it it's random self-centered and
there's no leadership in the in the
government no no on
in the in the anti-establishment faction
yeah i don't i don't like cult worship
in general i don't think a
a a guy or a girl can like come out and
be like i can do it like you elon musk
kind of but then
you know his whole bitcoin debacle
screwed a bunch of people he's not for
himself
right and you can only ever be out for
yourself first and you should be out for
yourself first the left is out for a
collective victory
and everyone else are out for themselves
they're all out for themselves too they
do it in the guise of a collective no no
but it all serves the collective
i guess as long as their cult ideology
expands
they benefit from it on the right though
there's conflict between even people who
are anti-establishment
yeah absolutely yeah and there should be
the left does eat them
you fire you know a fire on each other
as well the circular firing squad for
sure
i think there should be conflict between
we should all have healthy conflict
at you know you never want to subserve
to another human
really i don't think even in a marriage
you know you want there to be healthy
conflict and communication
not in this confrontation at the very
least if not conflict but
so we need a system that allows for that
obviously i don't think a human is going
to come and be like i will follow me
everyone like the captain america
but we'll build a system difficult
that's a lot harder to get people to do
than to throw molotov cocktails at
buildings or
scream down people who disagree with you
politically
and it's it's it's also vague like how
do you tell someone how to live morally
like that's a
challenging like jordan peterson does
eight hour
you know lectures just just about that
about one way that you can
but you have more just 100 but i'd also
say and this is part of what being
conservative is is recognizing the
age-old wisdom just saying like these
are the virtues people need to live
these out as best they can that's
what we have to encourage our followers
to do i've said this before but
conservatism has very much become this
very
loose affiliation of people who have
kind of vaguely similar ideas about the
economy
and oftentimes it falls back on this
philosophy of just like leave me alone
and let me do whatever i want
which is actually more classically
liberal exactly exactly
we need something much more robust and
this is why i've always said we need
something much more robust i've said
more recently more robust and rooted in
catholicism and
what i'm saying there too is something
really really well rooted in
virtues and people living their lives
in an upright fashion and i don't think
that's too vague if you're referencing
the virtues specifically
like the reason i refer to it as vague
is because when you're like
antifa's like we're going to throw a
brick you know that's like a call to
action like pick this up and do it and
then it's done but like if you're like
live humbly be humble like that's a
vague command
you know so how do you implement the
virtues
that's fair well and i think too a lot
of what they talk about is
tearing the system down and they
deconstruct everything philosophically
they don't necessarily have to put
anything forward in terms of what should
replace the system once it's been
removed
so they're not in the business of
building things whereas we're supposed
to be
so again that's an edge that they have
they're destroying things
exactly and that's the point that's
their goal
i guess a good way to exude virtue is to
make internet video
and show people like make cartoons do it
yourself become it yourself and then
allow people to
to witness interesting yeah mockery is
is good
but it seems to be i guess uh not as
effective it's been 10 years
the the who'd have thought that when you
saw you know gamergate
that these cultists would have reached
the highest levels of government
the presidential office i never would
have and and it happened six years it
really is so weird
but i didn't know that honestly it
doesn't surprise me at all
so the so the the so the the right or
the anti-establishment we want to call
it
has lost every step of the way
politically absolutely yeah some
victories here and there some you know
some some victories in certain areas but
uh
trump was only holding back the the
title floods you know
actually tim what happened was we won so
much we got tired of winning
so we decided to start losing all that
he wants to play with someone that can't
lose yeah yeah
donald trump won and a lot of people
felt that was it and
the good example of that is 2018. people
voted for trump
because they don't care for the
republicans or the democrats many of
these people trump wins but he won like
but with only 8 000 votes across three
states which gave him a good electoral
college victory
come 2018 those people didn't come out
and vote
so the data suggests that the people
said i voted for trump i'm done
that was it and then the democrats got
the house back and they used it to
burn everything to the ground 100
percent and
this is very easily evidenced by the the
victories of the republicans in 2020
so uh the polls were all off it was
funny looking at the new york times
arlene blue and they were solid red
and these were solid blue and some of
them flipped red like even an urban
center in florida turned red
because what happened was you had a
bunch of democrats say
we're not going to culture war you vote
for us we're going to get you health
care
yes and everyone said thank you the
first thing
these scumbags did exactly vote for
impeachment
nancy pelosi came over and they dropped
their knees and they licked her feet
and then they went and voted for
whatever she told them to vote for
and then many of them lost the
re-election because people were like i
don't care for you
you did not get us what we wanted but
still
it shows you that these democrats
promise all these things then deliver
nothing
well and this is part of why i think
again even though i will not make hard
and fast predictions here there is
there is some hope for a backlash
because i think when people vote
democrats it's
most often because they believe they
will provide them things like
inexpensive health care or worker
benefits they'll strengthen the unions
now i'm not saying the democrats
actually deliver on these things or that
the strategy democrats would take for
improving people's quality of life are
in any way
um effective but is what people
seem to want from democrats i don't
think people really want the woke
ideology
and so when they see the democrats
bending the knee
to these organizations like black lives
matter and antifun going off the deep
end with all the woke stuff
they're more likely to say well you guys
aren't doing the things that we actually
elected you to do you're just pandering
to the far left so
we're going to vote for republicans now
i don't i don't know if actually solves
anything when republicans don't actually
fight no no there's there's truth in
that too they come to your house and
they arrest you
they come to your house and arrest you
either way uh if it gets that bad the
point is you just have to be the best
possible person you can become
and if that happens and if enough of the
population actually cultivates virtue
then they could prevent that kind of a
disaster people could actually rise up
but i know that people not working on
themselves and not trying to become
better human beings only ends in
disaster for everybody
this last month i've been so focused on
being a better person and listening
and it's it's amazing how fast you can
change
if you really i mean you got to have
self-awareness but
yeah i mean we we all have things we
need to work on i definitely have a lot
i want to work on but when you think
about the fact that it really only takes
30 days to build a new habit i mean
that's incredible
anyone can change their life there could
be something that you've been doing
every day for 20 years and you just take
a month to do the opposite it's really
difficult but you'll end up building a
completely new habit
it's amazing sound like jordan peterson
it's like man it's like you you can
build new habits all you have to do is
get your life in order
i mean that's something clean the room
might clean your room that's something
my parents would tell me as a kid yeah
it takes 30 30 days to build a habit and
i'd be like
whatever you know as a kid you're like
30 days that's so much time
now it's like man a month just flies by
and i could be a significantly improved
person by the end of at the beginning of
the month that that's what i want for
myself
i think most months i like most other
people don't make that decision and i
should so like if you're changing a
habit
you just when you notice yourself doing
it you acknowledge
that you're doing it uh what do you mean
by that like
in terms of how you cultivate a habit
yeah i think so so give me an example of
something a person might want to change
oh like uh i don't know drinking coffee
in the morning
yeah so something they would want to
stop doing yeah you can't just
i think you're drinking coffee yeah so
so here's the thing i think usually they
say
the best way of stopping yourself from
doing something is to replace it with
something else
so for 30 days you would just say drink
tea every morning instead of coffee
and then by the end of that month
yeah exactly sometimes it has more
caffeine it can have more caffeine but
it doesn't have to be tea it can be
something else
you can just be like i have water every
morning it can be something that doesn't
even seem to have that much of an effect
but knowing that you have replaced one
thing with another thing actually builds
the habit of doing the second thing
you know you do it's easy it's like when
you when you're pouring your coffee just
pour
one ounce less every single day just a
tiny bit
for one week you pour one ounce less the
next week you do one ounce less
and then eventually you're having like a
small you know shot
that takes a lot of discipline too
though because what's to stop you at one
point for me like you know what today's
my cheat day and i'm just going to pour
the same thing and then
it's fine yeah but i think a lot of
people do a cheat day and then it just
becomes a whole thing
yep they just fall back i hear it a lot
from people like i'm doing keto i can't
eat a bowl of macaroni and cheese but
i'll make an exception for the bowl with
macaroni and cheese and i'm like okay
you're not done
yeah exactly exactly exactly it works
yeah yeah i i
i think um something no none of that
so how do you build a new habit of
something you want to learn how to do
like um oh i don't know listen
increase your listening skills yeah i
mean again i
i think um i'm no like expert or
self-help guru here but i would just say
that you have to start by just doing
that thing every day for 30 days and you
have to schedule it at a specific time
so that it works
its way into your schedule and then
eventually it just becomes a normal
thing to you that doesn't require as
much effort to get started with
and that's when it becomes a habit yeah
for me you know when i started making
videos every day at a certain time yeah
it was like it was like a personal
obligation yes
like i would i would feel a kind of
anguish if i didn't do what i was
supposed to do
you know like i decided like i got to do
this thing at that time and i
like every day at 4 pm i have a video
out and so like
like the nightmares that i've had few
and far be two and a half years without
missing a single
upload at one point it's it's very rare
that we missed one but
it that's what it was it was just an
obligation to myself saying like i have
to get this done
and the way it started was i took some
time away from uploading and just tried
to work on a bunch of videos at once
and i was still in college at the time
and so i was
in school while i was trying to keep up
with this once
a week schedule and i was keeping up
with it and then eventually at some
point
i just like ran out of extra videos and
then i had to actually create a new
video from scratch each week and
when the team was smaller at one point
it was basically just me doing
doing basically everything that entire
week
but i would just force myself to because
i couldn't let myself not upload that
week and
and now now you have this really
consistent schedule sometimes we do
twice a week we're trying to get twice a
week done
more often there are periods of time
where we'll do two weeks three even
you've been doing it long enough now so
where you know a lot of people don't
know this but uh
seamus doesn't actually do any of the
voices anymore it's all it's all korean
voices
korean anime
yeah i just worked 30 hours a day every
day every day
for me yeah exactly yeah i'm doing i do
an impersonation of sheamus doing an
impersonation of georgia oh that's why
it's so good
exactly okay it's wonderful tim is very
talented
that's why you should buy one of these
t-shirts to support him so this one's
going to freedomtunes.com
freedom tunes merch and it looked like
the nazis were about to take over the
entire world like it was basically it
looked like doomsday and
he just stayed positive he kept telling
people we're gonna get through this
it's gonna be okay i i it's going to be
it's going to work we're going to win
and he didn't know that
but his inspiration his confidence even
if he had to fake it worked
it got people it kept people excited
gave people hope
so i'm trying to go that route in
regards to what
the heck is going on with society right
now i know that
we can fix things you know we can
decentralize and and
the um the workload
so i imagine that we will evolutionism
is a form of necessity or in 20 years
the whole planet is woke
and it'll be a woke i sure hope so
dystopia
but you won't be allowed to express
those opinions
yeah so everything will be ultra woke
and you'll be able to express your
opinions and everyone will walk around
with a fake smile on their face
you see that here's the episode of
doctor who where they go to that planet
where it's like a colony it's a bunch of
robots with smiley faces like big
screens and smiley faces
and they don't realize what's happening
and then they have to wear badges that
have smiley faces on them
and what it is if they get sad then the
symbol on the
thing like changes or whatever to a sad
face and the story was that
the robots were tasked with keeping
everybody happy someone died
everybody got sad and the robots didn't
know why they were sad or how to stop it
because it was death so that eventually
they realized when the sad people went
and told other people someone died
those people got sad the robots then
looked at sadness like a contagion and
started exterminating anybody who was
said
because they were spreading sadness and
the death resulted in more sadness
so the doctor and things with claire
whatever name is they're walking with
like fake smiles on their faces
and their robots are like ding and
they're like just like smiling
otherwise they'll kill you that's what
it's going to be like in the future yeah
probably
and that's great because then everyone
will be happy yes right it's important
you see that remember remember remember
the treehouse of horror on simpsons
where he goes back in time
and then he's like flanders is in charge
yeah flanders in charge and
everyone yeah mo is lobotomized
and he's like renegation camps
yeah you're laughing but you're not
gonna be laughing when you're actually
walking in there yeah i will because
i'll have to be happy you know i'll be
faking i'm like that's right
this is great guys they're going to be
like okay who's the next uh freedom
yeah you think they're even going to try
to re-educate me dude i'm going to
educate
they're going to be like we want you to
start making
friendly tunes like look i've been
making biden tunes since like 2014 you
guys
huge fan of old joe no malarkey
i think they might actually accept that
they'll be like yeah we don't like joe
either
that was the old guard oh no yeah well i
was always a big joe biden
i see the marks on that t-shirt wait
what happened what are you saying what i
do have i have joe biden on this t-shirt
too as a lifeguard jameis from your legs
well it wouldn't be an accurate
depiction if you didn't have harry
potter he's actually what he does
he's just like dressed as a lifeguard up
here you gotta hurry legs
put in a rain barrel bang on a curb what
if it was biden re-education
and we just all had to learn to talk
like that because
remember when he said radio but then
corrected himself to record player or
whatever
yeah he's like sure on the radio the the
record player
he's like what was he i remember seeing
that live he was talking about
ways to be attentive to your child or
something or things that are good for
their intellectual development he's like
you talk to that kid when they're in
their crib you play the radio the record
players something really bizarre
i was like that is my president he was
trying to tell moms to stick their kid
in front of the ipad and press play and
walk away
so that they can watch videos of the
incredible hulk and adolf hitler doing
tai chi dances together while an indian
family sings nursery rhymes i appreciate
you shouting out my second channel so
it's you who made this thing
well you get the government you vote for
man yeah or don't vote for
if you didn't vote no i don't know
george carlin said don't blame me i
didn't vote for these people
yeah it's like what do you do you vote i
voted cody simpson's reference
don't blame me i voted for kodos
i'm not confident but um i am confident
in locality
you know i'm not confident in the
federal government but i'm confident you
know being out in the middle of nowhere
i think it's the cities that are in
trouble voting works
if you do it right if you have like a
local system you're like what do you
guys want for dinner tonight and
everyone's like i want you know
let's tally it up and then so it's not
i don't like i don't not that i don't
trust voting but i don't trust that like
voting another representative into
office is going to fix this freaking
account this be yeah
of course not we need to do that
ourselves
well as the people we elected who
destroyed this whole thing
yeah or that we didn't elect like the
head of the federal reserve the the
people that we
are appointed by the people we elected
so yeah a lot of people
like the parliamentarian in the senate
does it like
how many positions are just appointed
you know we're supposed to be a
republican it's fascinating because
you hear this argument about we're not a
democracy it's not supposed to be a
democracy
and i'm like well if you think about it
that way then the people who win in the
democracy like the democrats are just
the elites who manipulate and seize
power
so i guess what's what's the issue then
if we were actually functioning the way
the founding fathers intended
one of the problems that created the
17th amendment was that
the state governments felt the
appointments and the federal politicians
appointments to the senate were corrupt
so the wait used to be
you'd vote for your state
representatives they would appoint
senators to send to the federal
government
there was concern that people were just
buying these appointments
kind of like with you know
ambassadorships so then they were like
okay we shouldn't do this let's change
earth
is isn't is it like an organism it's it
is
like a god i disagree there that the
earth is a god i was actually going to
tweet that out
earth is a god i think i would have been
in your replies disagreeing with you you
wouldn't have heard it
it's hard i don't know it's just such a
powerful force and entity and like wind
and
everything moving in unison i think that
you should view the earth as the
individual components like you can look
at the dirt and find these really cool
things you can find worms you can
examine the grass you can look at
everything in nature and just be
incredibly amazed by it and probably the
way sheamus would go with that would be
there is an incredible creator
exactly somebody who put it together
every bit of this for every creature
that eats the grass and the worms
you know what i love exactly you know i
love symbolism right simulation theory
so the idea is we're in a simulation but
why would they make that
supposition why would they determine
that the the thing that we exist in
that it's a that it's a simulation right
wait who's they
like anybody elon musk he talks about
this right yeah so they say it's a
simulation we're in a computer program
and i'm like why
why is it a simulation is like a
facsimile representation of something
else so like
sim simulated flight right it's it's
that the implication is that they know
there's a top-level base reality that's
identical to ours in many ways
and we're simulated of it and i'm like
if you believe we're in a computer
program why wouldn't you say we're in a
construct
we are we are living within a programmed
construct
that's how i see gender tim what's a
program
a set of rules and commands that create
a system a great plan
that was put in place so it's funny when
they say simulation
the only difference between that and
saying we are in a in a constructed
reality by a greater power
is that they think we are built in the
image
of the reality that we come from which
turning it into
a perceived expression so we do live
within a simulate your environment is
simulated but that doesn't mean that
simulation theory is a real thing it
doesn't mean
it just like it is more if i think it
would be more of a constructed
you know what i'm saying is matrix if
you if it was one
would you call grand theft auto a
simulation no well it's like a driving
simulator
you know that's how i learned it's a
construct it's a constructed virtual
reality
i guess it's both so look i believe
what's sad about oh
no it's just that we got to a point
where we understood computers enough to
where we started describing our reality
like a simulation
and what they're basically saying is
that some higher power
created a simulated version of their
reality for which we live in
i'm like dude that just sounds like
religion but you're trying to like spin
it and we sort of talked about this
before i think in one of my earlier
appearances but people sort of
view that as like a more sophisticated
approach to religion but it's actually
much more rudimentary because what
you're doing is you're just applying all
of these human characteristics to god
and still instead of saying like we are
created in god's image and likeness
you're saying
like god creates like with tools the way
that we we create and he's like
kind of disinterested in his creation
the way that we are with the things we
create
like in in the the christians you can
start breaking the paper clips down to
create energy to make more paperclips
and you
amass all carbon life on earth to create
more paper then you
send drones out into space that make
paper clips out of themselves no for
real
yeah and at one point do you care about
any one of those individual paper clips
because if they're
i don't i care that there are 600
trillion of them in my
account but i don't know not one of them
matters to me
yeah let's go to super chats yeah let's
do it we'll go to super chats to the
best of our abilities because the
internet's been all whacked out
it's been it's been rough dude i woke up
at 4am the smoke alarm going off yeah
fire department comes out
like people are are just like i don't
want to go outside and i'm like the
smoke alarm went off and the fire
department's coming
get out of the house i wanted to vlog i
got up i left immediately
ian started playing drums yeah i just
went out i was like i want to go back
to sleep after this dude
could you hear it in the house dude it
was no i was still sitting outside i was
like i'm just gonna like sit up against
this tree and get a little bit of
shut-eye
and then and then ian's like i have
other plans
i am the greatest drummer impersonation
oh i don't know if i could do one yet i
got to spend a little more time let's go
read some superheroes
all right uh for everybody who hung out
as long as you did hey thanks for
hanging out i know it's been all wonky
yeah
when we upload this to um to itunes
spotify you're not gonna notice any
breaks
but you will notice us saying things
like the internet's out again
a lot which you don't hear because
youtube just like skips it over
so i actually think you know like we're
we're live for like two hours the
youtube
video will be like an hour like 12
minutes it's rough
yeah uh but we'll uh we'll reach the
protection
super chat thanks for hanging out and
smash the like button and become a
member at timecast.com
because the bonus segment will have no
interruptions because it's recorded and
then uploaded
all right and you know what else just go
to
dot com freedomtunesmerch.com gonna
break me oh yeah all right stairs into
space gaming says
hey tim wanted to say thanks for
recommending crypto back in december
recommendation for graphene production
pays off for you
as much as krypto did for me also shout
out to my fellow graphene disciple ian
cheers
i i i invested uh a decent amount in a
company that makes script
uh makes graphene and uh it's it's done
well what's graphene
it's this stuff don't it's a it's a
single lattice
and
all right all right image jpeg says tim
please get ron paul on
all that's going on is on purpose a
history of money and banking in the us
shows corruption going far into the past
ron paul has a standing invitation to
come on this show whenever he wants i'm
a big fan of ron and rand he's amazing
yep the micro titan says here is your
donation
tim buy a new house um
we're going to be setting up some uh
where we're hiring you know let's put it
that way i'll leave it there i won't get
too expensive i actually had a question
um regarding the cost of lumber and
steel going up are house prices also
going up as a result or just
constructing the houses yeah yes so like
the value of the lumber in the house is
calculated into the value of that well
so so here's what's happening
in order to build a new house it's like
30 to 40 000
more expensive to build the house
because of lumber cost and steel
so what happens then is a house that
would normally a new construct that
would sell for 200 000 sells for
250 which means the value of the
neighboring houses
is also going to rise the same time
because if peop so it's just
market forces if someone's like why buy
a new house if the house next to it
is the same price well then people don't
build new houses then there's no supply
then someone builds a new house and then
someone is forced to buy the more
expensive house
and then the people are like i'm not
going to sell my house if the new houses
are going for the same price
i'm going to ask for a premium so now
you've got people in dc the famous story
we talked about
a million dollars over asking what
coincidences all right let's see
what we got pioneer smoke houses says
jim worthington from newtown athletic
club is suing move on for malicious and
malicious and defamatory move on his
trash everything they say is leftist
well i mean thomas b moore says heads up
ian trump signed the farm bill in 2018
with hemp and cbd legalization in it
usda finalized and released regulations
on january 15
2021. excellent
evil zombie hampshire says was bitcoin
invented or discovered
glad to see you back seamus thank you
i'm glad to be back
and to answer your question no real
quick
that's a question i suppose that's a
question we could ask about just about
anything that gets created
right uh rye ch says ian may be right
according to an article on reason
trump had a nine percent tax and biden
is planning to double it
and make it retroactive to 2019 putting
importers on the hook for back tariffs
oh wow that would be such a good idea
girls were like we turn and smile at the
camera
yes and then like yeah just like the
full house intro dude you started like
like the big shot of the big tim house
and it's like
we'll do a simpsons catch gag we'll do
uh uh we'll do one with ian going super
saiyan i'm so into it
yeah fighting sheamus okay wait what
uh android sheamus 17 yeah that'll be
character
like i'll have a cool catchphrase and
stuff you'll be like the bar and
the grime bar you'll turn and smile no
no ian's who would
what character would ian be in dragon
ball z oh dude i didn't watch dragon
ball z i don't know i don't have a cable
tim come on yeah i don't know if there's
a character that would represent you
very well
let's go get creative all right bring
her a bringer of d
says tim fyi red flannel isn't a
requirement but there's 20 beaver bucks
towards
the the lumber towards your lumberjack
future
go get yourself a good axe and learn how
to sharpen and maintain your tools
most of it can be done with a good file
well there you go
what is this km says when is there going
to be a stoned tim cast or a drunk one
see ian singing grateful dead or fish
songs lol san dimas high school football
rules
there you go that's a bill in town ted
reference san dimas rules
i'd love to have a rock and roll podcast
one of these nights rock and roll yeah
let's play some music
roger b says i work at a at a plastic
injection company and it's getting hard
to get the raw plastic to run
the non-medical uh to run the
non-medical part
nor can we get people to run the press
wow we bought 3d printers we got a bunch
of them
dude you ever see a resin printer no
you've seen it residential i love them i
don't even know what it is
so resin's liquid and they use uh what's
ultraviolet right yeah they
multiple ways but that's one of them
ultraviolet light hardens it so what
happens is
there's a screen and there's resin and
then a plate touches the resin
and then the light from the uv hits the
the
plate hardening the resin on the plate
and the plate slowly moves up
it looks like it's pulling something out
of the resin
it's crazy but it's just hardening in
sequential order so like as it lifts up
you'll see like the figure
and so if you were like painting like a
if you if you were printing like a resin
horse
you would see like the hooves and then
the body and then it would like lift up
and you're like
whoa it looks like it just pulls it out
of nothing like magic i think they're
making
like organic compounds out of like
chemical resin soup
i could be wrong but i remember seeing
like resin printers that were printing
like living structures and stuff out
like they just pull the heart out of the
goo
or something like that or the kidney or
something
i think andy plays the game says tim
about the sleeping bag thing
no use borg alcoves much more expensive
in a way to sync money
oh wait no computer chips available
never mind oof bummer
dude we've been waiting for two months
on this computer still not here we
should buy more computers you should
i tried more dude there was like the
inventory is just trash
so we had to we we need it we need a
network terminal we need some
workstations
and they're just really bad it's like
the bottom of the barrel at this point
it's rough
dude very weird and they're saying oh
it's like demand is so high but supply
isn't caught up yet and i'm like
yeah if people can't buy the thing they
want to buy what's going to incentivize
them to go make things
it's like if i want to buy a computer
and i can't get it then my money isn't
doesn't have the same value
if the computer was sitting there shiny
and sparkly and i'd be like man
i got to go get a job so i could buy
that computer yeah like you know
computer the way
technology works is we build it off of
what we had already built so like a
laser you get a diamond or crystal that
focuses the laser to cut another crystal
smaller
to make a better laser that can cut the
crystal even smaller to make another
laser that can cut it
so you make these better so if all of a
sudden every laser and every crystal was
just
gone and we had to start from scratch
again i don't know that we would be able
to build these advanced machines
or without the without i mean obviously
we have if we have the data
and the understanding of how to get
there we'll get there faster but we
still would need to recreate the
step-by-step system i think dj maverick
says it's my first super chat and i was
wondering if you have control on what
ads you have on your videos
because this ad popped up and it scared
me because of what it is i tweeted at
you
can't link it here no it's automatic
systems so on the podcast and on youtube
it's like totally automated system
there are uh some ads where i literally
do the reads and that appears in the
podcast those are the ones that are like
sent to me and they're like what do you
think and i'm like oh that's cool
but then most ads are just automated
systems yeah so it was funny like when
bloomberg was advertising on my uh
my videos where i was like bloomberg's
trash that's funny and then a video
appears like i'm michael bloomberg
there were bloomberg videos everywhere
for
dude it was like a strange couple weeks
i did yeah they were like
let me just show you the story real
quick real quick why a leesburg
restaurant plans to serve asian cicadas
now instead of the local variety
they say late last week the luden the
loudoun county health department told
cochina on market in leesburg to stop
selling
its newly popular cicada tacos the
reason according to the health
department
was that the cicadas which were being
foraged for locally
were not coming from an approved source
that's right
you can't just eat and sell grubs and
bugs you found
so this was happening literally in
leesburg the guy was going there's a
video of him walking in the argument
here's a good one and grabbing a cicada
and throwing in like a jar or something
so this was literally happening and i
tell people hey don't eat those because
they're not properly sourced
and now the health department has said
yes you can't do that tim you
specifically told me to eat as many as i
possibly could
you're like just go out back i was like
hey tim hey tim what are you doing what
are you doing what are you doing
like just go out in the backyard eat as
many cicadas as you can
i was like all right dude they're flying
around like crates just don't work and
they're just throwing the chickens
yeah so like i can walk up and just boop
them into the jar and then throw the jar
in the chicken coop and the chickens go
nuts and just
maul them like crazy but the ones that
are flying around
i just you know pop you would hit them
out of the air
yeah that's awesome yeah and then they
just like flutter down
and then killing for a purpose is nice
like hunting yeah
i got chickens to feed bro i used to i
knew kids in fifth grade that would take
the plastic bat out and
hit lightning bugs i might have told you
guys that's that's what yeah i wouldn't
do it i
just felt morally like corrupt by and i
felt all sad and they didn't want to be
my friend but it wasn't worth it you
must serve
negative entropy had we been feeding the
goal of
of hunting the cicadas was to contribute
to the expansion of chicken
chicken yes there's no destruction in it
it was
the cicada was becoming one with the
chicken so the chicken could become more
yeah just killing this caterpillar of
killing it's messed up cicadas to egg
but
i i do have a rule the chickens that
escape
i let them escape escape like cicadas
this is chickens wait what the chickens
are getting
the cicadas that escape so
when i'm walking along the bush yeah
well i know but hold on so what
i went to sweden i covered the story i
was a bit of the story to the swedes but
i was there to report to americans
and so i report what was going on and i
said i'm gonna do my videos
i won't go back to sweden i went to
thailand at a documentary on the
conflict there and afterwards it
embarrassed some very powerful people
and they said you don't want to go back
so i didn't
when you're when you're assigning
journalists to do stories you don't send
a woman into tahrir square because they
were literally raping women
so why would you just create that risk
we have security protocols for these
things
so andy is the number one prime target
for antifa
he is allowed to be a journalist i get
that women should be allowed to walk
around at night without fear of being
raped but rapists exist
so i think personal responsibility is a
tremendous opportunity with the support
of all of you clearly
love what he does to expand his
operation and use his experience his
know-how to allow other people to expand
now instead of having just one andy know
andy can help lead ten
andy knows and with your support helping
him fund it he could do something much
more powerful
james o'keefe isn't gonna isn't going to
go inside planned parenthood or facebook
and it's organizations anymore
he started an organization he hired
people now they do it and he leads the
charge
that's the way it is the world should be
certain ways but it isn't the real world
is not
you know what we want it to be and
that's just uh that's life yeah we
talked about last night a little bit
this has been andy's been on my mind a
lot for about
10 months because after he got hurt like
last august or something it really
disturbed me and there's this like trope
of the young
soldier the young warrior prince who
like goes out and leads the troops for
years and years and years and fights on
the front lines but then eventually
retires to the throne room
because his experience and intellect is
too valuable to risk
on the front lines and and that on top
of being well known
by sight obviously you can't put
yourself in danger physically
you need you need to retire i mean
that's that's not not what you don't
need to but expand
yeah yeah honestly more if you can
become an administrator and administrate
other young warriors to lead the charge
that's the idea of the ancient king you
know
it's the evolution of the of the young
prince into the the old king i mean he
a lot of the work he was still doing was
aggregating information and being that
source for people
so he knows who to follow he knows where
to get that key information
he's still able to report without being
in the midst of like a local anti-fun
you know group or whatever
so now he can actually hire new people
who does i guess
oh i don't know if people know what
we're talking about andy went um
undercover
to antifa was in portland i think yeah
and then they found out it was him they
and then
chased him and and imagine if andy had
an operation like veritas
where instead of just him going down for
one protest
he had 10 people across the country at
all of their meetings yeah you'll get
people in antifa that contact you andy
uh via email it's telling you and giving
you undercover stuff it'll be great
it's time to go big all right let's see
let's uh see we got jamie chaffin says i
was told they already won
i said the wrong doors have not been
knocked on yet they don't understand
when they knock on the wrong doors they
will have an answer
maybe daniel young says tim needs
starlink or other reliable isp to stream
we have satellite
we quite literally have a satellite
backup it's not working
yeah something happened when the power
got knocked out
it affects the whole area for in a
variety of reasons but that doesn't
explain satellite
i don't know why the satellite is
probably our internal network got
got frazzled yeah so we're gonna have to
do some kind of reset you know
okay that's what it is a great reset
it's gotta be great
kel non-telf says mike lindell just sued
dominion for 2 billion
his evidence package from an infosec
side is a smoking gun
showing 555 864 votes switched from
trump to biden
basically if he's not fabricating
evidence it's indisputable proof
so that's kind of what i'm saying and
start focusing on hiring more people
because so so long as i'm spending you
know 8 a.m to 4 p.m recording
and then having only a few hours to do
like banking stuff and then i do this
show i don't have time to actually hire
and expand
so if i had if i allocated more like the
mornings to actually
hiring people and expanding then
we'd probably weigh bigger way faster
you could just hire me to be the
replacement tim i'll do those videos for
you you get me a beanie boy gotcha
in front of that camera have you done it
yeah have the illinois boys sub in for
you some days it's me some days it's
jack there you go we know all your
opinions
true very excited no i mean at a certain
point i have to i have to recognize that
you know what i mean
is it effective for me to keep just
recording three hours every single day
or
what's your ideal like um life
what do you mean like if you could pick
like it's happening how you want it to
happen what is your what's a natural day
for you
literally what's happening but i mean
you say you need to do less
videos to do more administrators so i
can focus more on hiring people and
growing the company
but you like the doing the videos uh the
the challenges that i stopped doing
videos a lot of the money stops coming
in
my dad was a lieutenant fireman
lieutenant and had an opportunity to
become a captain but didn't want to
because he didn't want to take the desk
job
yeah he liked being there with men and
like leading the group into the house
uh i don't know diana cooper says
blackberry rocket rocket rocket smiley
smiley smiley
is blackberry skyrocketing apparently oh
we have a mulberry tree
oh i still haven't had to do i ate some
of those today dude did you like them
really good yeah
they're kind of bland yeah tree berries
i mean they're not incredible but you
know it's just it's free food from
outside i felt like an
primitivist i was like this is how it
should have this i was like this is what
they took from us
there's a cicada and it's holding the
mulberry like standing on it and you
pick him
and you get both same i know i eat both
at the same time and honestly they're
delicious i don't know what you guys are
talking about with this fungus that's
so what do you do take the mulberries
mix it with sugar yeah of course yeah
i was just trying to eat mulberries you
take the mulberries you got to get the
stems off them and then you like we'll
put in a pan
and you'll put sugar in it and you just
cook it put some lemon juice in it some
other juice with it and then it simmers
down what do you mean
i think that they're not sweet enough oh
well you put you put sugar in it oh okay
yeah just some regular sorry what nature
has to provide isn't good enough for you
guys that's right i'm sorry the food
that literally
i mean it's actually you know like if
you're doing keto you can have berries
because berries don't have a lot of
sugar in them depending on the berries
yeah like mulberries like it's not
they're not very sweet they're kind of
they have fiber in them yeah yeah that's
right
all right let's see we'll do a uh a
couple more dc super chats
fish uh long john silver commercial and
there goes your uh there goes your
shipping container idea
i want to build a building material
right ryan c says ian is chatsu
and like i guess it's as close as you
can get because chatsu's got second
powers
okay that's my yeah but chatsu is like a
tiny floating little like
imaginary thing i'd be the guy you find
if you're like playing a game and you
come up on this dude this like wizard
dude that's fighting off like three
goblins or whatever he's getting getting
beat down and if if you don't save him
he dies but if you save him he joins you
and he's like this weird like wizard guy
mark jensen says as if ian didn't make
much sense before
try having the internet cut out and then
back to mid-range
because that's all yeah yeah what if
he's like actually listen the thing
about graphene
you've got all this material in eclipse
and so when the aliens are coming i feel
so sorry
and that's when the fungus effect mostly
made sense over here
no uh i looked at the transcript and
actually it never cut out when ian was
talking that was just how he said music
yeah what are you talking about the
international formulator
all right we got a couple more let's see
legitimate uh legitimate
legend math guyon regarding what you
were earlier talking about where one day
we'll have blm flags everywhere in a
little while later you need to report to
the gulag
i think the language needs a new word
frog boiling progressive bad faith
harmful aggression love you guys
yeah yeah the the frogs
all right let's see we got sonny james
says did you guys hear
uh did you guys hear about the actual
soil dying in parts uh and useful only
for gmo seeds
talk about the utmost disaster
capitalism erin brockovich sounded the
alarm on infertility
could you imagine if you had to get the
government's assistance to reproduce
yikes this is like the um genetically
modified corn that would
are they saying it would infect the soil
and make it so you would need to keep
getting that same genetically modified
seed in order to grow it in your area
yes
yeah they would do that it's almost like
they hold like the the farmer they
blackmail these farmers by getting them
on this like genetically modified plant
and then they they they're
handy they have to keep buying the
pesticides you know the glyphosate or
whatever
all right all right yeah well two more
here nicholas grenier says did you see
the hills poll showing that 83
of americans support government action
against china if lab leak theory proven
true
did you see the story where chinese
state media threatened nuclear war if
it's almost like russia wasn't the
biggest threat for all this time we were
told that russia was the biggest threat
imagine world war iii breaking out with
joe biden as president
i can say it faster than he said it no
shop at a shop i could say it faster
than you should say
trim and shaft of the pressure truman
nana shabbat pressure
would probably turn it on a shot at
pressure shooter shout out to a pressure
calculator better calf here
should it not have the pressure
smash the like button smash the like
button if you don't want to hear me and
sheamus just keep saying the same things
over and over again go to timcast.com
for the bonus segment which will be
coming up a little bit
uh it was brutal i i mentioned like the
fire alarm thing and like going out in
the morning like my back hurts
oh wild yeah that was jarring getting
woken up i was actually still awake but
you asked what do you mean yeah what are
you talking about it was jar getting
woken up oh
and i started playing the drums i saw
some fireman there was exhausted
it's brutal because like my schedule is
so jam-packed yeah i get literally like
seven hours of sleep perfectly as long
as i'm undisturbed so waking up at four
i'm just like
yeah you guys are sunk and i'm like i
know tim punched me in the head it was
awful oh i was just brutally
i mean sheamus were like we were
fighting in the air like clashing yeah
it was pretty bad that was
partially and then you know he did the
big bang attack and i did kamehameha and
then like the whole sky lit up
sorry i missed this they still haven't
hair turns blonde
exactly and we'll see you all thanks for
hanging out uh you can follow the show
at tim cast
uh timcast irl on instagram and facebook
share our videos you can follow me at
tim cast
subscribe to this channel smash the like
button and
i am deeply impressed with everybody who
watched this broken internet video
we had a massive storm hit us so we'll
have to just like reboot the internet
and get it sorted
and then uh just probably set up a
protocol for checking
audio visual internet before every show
so it never happens again
but you know we are kind of in the
middle of nowhere so it happens but uh
sheamus i hear you have t-shirts that
broke on
broke the internet i have t-shirts that
broke this stream so if you want to
support me at breaking tim's streams up
first of all just go to youtube.com
freedomtunes we make cartoons we release
them every single week sometimes twice a
week
and i also have these t-shirts for sale
if you want to support what we're doing
freedomtunesmerch.com is the website for
those
so youtube.com freedom tunes check that
out subscribe please subscribe
trying to grow as much as we can and uh
yeah also purchase some shirts so that
we can fund the show
thanks sheamus you're welcome i love you
i love you um thanks guys thanks for
coming and listening to talk about
graphene and new technologies
i had a great time follow me ian
crossland.net and at ian crosson on
social media
you get my music on spotify and amazon
things like that
great i have never been so happy that i
don't live at the studio
between the cicadas and being woken up
at four in the morning it does sound
exciting though i have to say maybe i
feel like i should feel like i missed
out a little bit but i'm better rested
than these guys are
you guys can follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlids as i attempt to overtake
sourpatch kids we will see you guys
at timcast.com in the members only
exclusive where sheamus does the whole
show by himself
jordan peterson alex jones ben shapiro
and dr fauci arguing with each other